bonjour à tous je suis ravie de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat c'est une
niche fiscale qui plaît beaucoup aux
entreprises le crédit impôt recherche
les fonds alloués à ce dispositif ont
grimpé en flèche depuis 2008 ils ont
dépassé les 5 milliards et demi d'euros
l'an dernier le principe de ce
dispositif est très simple plus une
entreprise embauche de chercheurs plus
elle dépense en frais de recherche et
plus elle bénéficie d'une petite
ristourne d'impôts mais ce succès cache
parfois des abus une commission
d'enquête sur le détournement de crédit
impôt recherche a d'ailleurs été créée
en décembre dernier au Sénat elle est
présidée par l'UMP Francis de lâtre avec
comme rapporteur la communiste Brigitte
gonther main cette commission d'enquête
auditionnée cette semaine les
représentants du groupe Renault son
directeur financier et son directeur de
la recherche pour cause le groupe
Renault a été accusé a été mise en cause
dans un reportage diffusé au journal de
20h de France Télévision de détourner
une partie de l'enveloppe du crédit
impôt recherche je vous laisse découvrir
tout de suite cette audition dans un
climat vous allez le voir parfois très
tendu on va pas se polariser tout de
suite sur le reportage on va d'abord
vous allez d'abord si vous si vous êtes
d'accord nous expliquer comment
globalement le dispositif s'applique
chez Renault ce que vous en pensez et
vous donnerz les chiffres aussi
actualisés
donc je vous donne monsieur j'imagine
monsieur Thorman la parole je vous en
prie
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président
bonjour bonjour madame la rapporteur et
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
permettez-moi tout d'abord de vous
remercier de m'inviter à ce ainsi que
mes collègues du groupe renao à
s'exprimer devant la commission
d'enquête sur la réalité du détournement
du cire de son objet et son incidence
sur la situation de l'emploi la
recherche dans notre pays ce sera
l'occasion pour nous de rappeler
l'importance du dispositif du cire pour
notre société pour notre groupe mais
aussi pour la recherche dans notre pays
al chaque mot choisi dans l'intitulé de
votre commission d'enquête à son
importance je citerai réalité
détournement sire emploi et notre pays
c'est pourquoi je me permets en liminire
de partager avec vous trois affirmation
clé la première d'entre elles est que la
réalité du groupe renao dans son emploi
du crédit impô recherche c'est-à-dire
des moyens publics consentis par la
collectivité nationale c'est l'absence
de détournement de l'objet du cire j'ai
la chance d'être aujourd'hui auditionné
au Sénat devant une commission d'enquête
de la Haute Assemblée c'est justement le
Sénat qui a produit en 2012 un rapport
bipartisan qui fait référence ou qui
fera référence pendant de nombreuses
années et dont le rapporteur était le
sénateur Michel Berson qui est membre de
votre commission d'enquête le rapport
relatif au crédit d'impôt recherche et
parmi les principales mesures de ce
rapport du Sénat figurait une
perspective d'instauration d'un taux
unique du cire de 20 % pour les grandes
entreprises afin de supprimer et je le
cite l'effet d'ben qu'il constitue pour
elle alors Renau en 2014 a investi 2
Millard 30 millions d'euros en recherche
et développement près des 3/4 ont été
investis en France soit un montant de
15ard00 millions d'euros et de ce
montant
777 millions d'euros était éligible au
cire donc pour un total de cire de 143
millions
d'euros si nous avions un régime unique
des 20 % 20 % de ce même montant de 777
millions d'euros ça donnerait 155
millions soit plus que ce que nous
percevons aujourd'hui donc avec 143
millions d'euros il n'y a décidément pas
d'effet d'auè chez Renault ce qui
correspond concrètement à la première
préoccupation de votre commission
d'enquête
la deuxième affirmation clé pour nous
est que le crédit d'impôt recherche a
permis à Renault d'être bien placé dans
la course mondiale à l'innovation et de
fermer aucun site en France
contrairement à d'autres constructeurs
automobiles également bénéficiaires du
cire et de créer des emplois en France
le 12 février dernier Renault a annoncé
2000 recrutements en France dès 2015 en
1000 en CDI et 1000 contrats
d'apprentissage pour nos jeunes au titre
de ces 1000 CDI Renault embauche plus
par particulièrement 500 personnes en RD
en France ce qui répond concrètement à
la deuxème préoccupation de votre
commission trème affirmation Renault ne
polémique jamais avec aucun média en
France nonobstant les les affirmations
non conforme à la réalité susceptible
d'être véhiculé tout en se réservant
d'engager chaque fois que nécessaire les
actions de protection de l'entreprise
ceci pour une raison très simple c'est
que dans notre société médiatique et
court termist Ron n'a pas vocation à se
transformer en attaché de presse de
reportage en quête de Bose de notoriété
et de
sensationalisme Renault entreprise aux
racines françaises profondément ancrée a
une responsabilité sociale particulière
et une activité sérieuse assurer la
compétitivité et la performance de ces
voitures dans la mondialisation créer
des emplois et développer une industrie
majeure alors permettez-moi monsieur le
Président avec tout le respect que je
vous dois et que je dois à votre
commission d'enquête de manifester quand
même ma surprise devant la diffusion
très inhabituelle dans cette enceinte
d'un reportage à sensation exclusivement
à charge et erroné cette audition n'en
est donc plus qu'indispensable elle
permettra d'opposer la réalité des faits
au choc fallacieux des images et des
propos mensongers je vous propose
d'organiser mon propos en trois temps je
présenterai d'abord comme vous me l'avez
demandé certains éléments de contexte
propre à l'industrie automobile qui me
semble important d'avoir en tête afin
d'aborder le sujet du S
je reviendrai avec vous sur certains
éléments qui méritent me semble-t-il une
attention toute particulière pour
terminer j'exposerai notre stratégie en
matière de recherche et innovation en
illustrant par des exemples concrets
l'usage que le groupe Reno fait de son
cire au terme de cet exposé nous serons
avec mon collègue Gaspar gascon à Bellon
qui est directeur donc comme vous le
disiez de l'ingénierie de notre groupe
et moi-même à votre entière disposition
pour vos questions alors d'abord le
contexte il est important d'avoir
présent esprit les évolutions de
l'industrie automobile mondiale ces 15
dernières années avec un déplacement des
foyers de croissance du marché
automobile en dehors des frontières
européennes le développement que connaît
l'industrie automobile hors d'Europe est
sans commune mesure avec la situation
observé dans les marchés français et
européens au cours des 15 dernières
années le marché automobile mondial a
ainsi enregistré une croissance de près
de 60 % passant de 54 millions de
véhicules vendus dans au travers le
monde euh en 1999 à plus de 85 millions
en 2014 en revanche et dans le même
temps le marché européen enregistré une
baisse de 13 %. sur la même période des
15 dernières années la part de l'Europe
dans les ventes automobiles mondiales a
ainsi été pratiquement divisé par 2
certains pays du sud de l'Europe ont
connu des baisses allant jusqu'à 50 % du
marché au cours de la crise de l'euro
quant au marché français il a enregistré
une baisse semblable de 14 % en 15 ans
ainsi la part de la France dans le
marché mondial est passé d'environ 5 %
en 1999 à 2,5 % l'année dernière et dans
ce contexte d'intense compétition
commerciale au niveau mondial le groupe
Renault s'est attaché à mener une
stratégie de développement de ses ventes
hors d'Europe celle-ci qui représenté 11
% du total des ventes du groupe en 1999
ont atteint 46 % en 2014 soit une
progression de 35 points en l'espace de
15 ans s'agissant de la France ce marché
représente désormais 20 % des ventes du
groupe alors qu'elle représentait plus
de 40 % il y a il y a 15 ans si les
ventes du groupe Renault ont suivi
l'évolution du marché mondial ce n'est
pas le cas des efforts de recherche et
développement qui sont majoritairement
restés en France en effet si la France
représente 20 % de nos ventes 75 % de
nos dépenses de Red y sont réalisées par
ailleurs le nombre de brevets déposés
reste toujours élevés ces dépôts ont
représenté 608 brevets en France en 2014
positionnant Renault dans le trio de
tête français l'intégralité de la
propriété intellectuelle a ainsi été
maintenue en France mais nous y
reviendrons plus tard en outre et je
l'expliquerai plus tard l'activité
française de Red du groupe a même été
développée pour le compte de partenaires
étrangers Nissan demmler General Motors
par exemple alors je souhaite insister
maintenant sur quelques points
d'attention particulière quatre points
en particulier il s'agit de la baisse
prétendue des dépenses de Red du groupe
Rono tandis que le C augmente la
qualification de l'une de nos filiales
historique idvu et je cite de pompe
Afrique le fait que la création récente
de filial teles que Airdream et idvu
idve pardon soit constitutive d'un abus
de droit et enfin l'absence de personnel
dans les filiales vous me permettrez de
revenir successivement sur chacun de ces
points concernant l'évolution des
dépenses du Red il est faux d'affirmer
que depuis 2008 les dépenses de Red de
Renault n'ont cessé de baisser tandis
que dans le même temps le cire aurait
augmenté
la red des entités Renault varie au gré
de l'intensité et des pics de recherche
en toute logique les dépenses éligible
au sirire vari également et suivent la
même courbe comme nous l'avons indiqué à
plusieurs reprises les dépenses de RD
sont orientées à la hausse depuis 2008
avec une augmentation globale de 8,3 %.
par ailleurs les effectifs d'ingénieur
en France étaient stables avant les
embauches annoncées en février dernier
et enfin le montant du cire est rest est
également stable sur la période
deuxièmement concernant la création
soi-disant récente de idvu alors idvu ça
veut dire ingénierie développement
véhicules
utilitaires et de sa qualification je
cite à nouveau de pompe Afrique la mise
en place de filiade de groupe Reno a
toujours eu pour pour origine la
nécessité de répondre à certaines
contraintes opérationnelles de
nombreuses activités du groupe Reno sont
organisées en France au sein de filiales
sans que cela ait la moindre cause
fiscale il s'agit dans la plupart des
cas de raisons managérial ou
opérationnell pour autant ces opérations
ne sont pas susceptibles d'être qualifié
d'abus de droit contrairement à ce qui a
été affirmé je tiens à souligner que
idvu n'a pas été créé en 2009 pour
augmenter le cire du groupe Renau idvu a
été créé en 1966 c'est une cette société
est issue de la fusion de deux bureaux
d'études externes Cros et kik
anciennement chausson ingénierie et qui
ont été intégrés à cette époque au
groupe chonau cette société réalise des
dépenses éligibles au sirire depuis plus
de 15 ans avant même la modification
législative de 2008 ces dépenses de Red
éligiblebles au cire étaient importantes
elles s'élevaient à 87 millions en 2007
contre 65 millions en 2008 l'analyse
chronologique du montant des dépenses
éégibles du cire généré par idvu depuis
plus de 10 ans permet de constater que
le passage dans la loi de finances pour
2008 d'un système de cire en
accroissement à un système de cire en
volume déplafonné n'a entraîné en
pratique aucune augmentation des
dépenses de recherche d'idvu éligible au
cire mais au contraire une baisse il est
donc inexact de sous-entendre qui DVU
serait je cite à nouveau une pompe
Afrique destinée depuis 2009 à augmenter
le cire de Renault lesffet démontre en
effet le contraire par ailleurs ce
constat est également valable pour nos
filiales Renault Dream Airdream et
idve ainsi pour ce qui est de la
création récente de Renault dream et
idve également montré du doigt comme un
abus de droit je me dois de réagir bien
évidemment la création de ces deux
entités a eu un impacte bénéfique sur le
cire de Renault nous ne le contestons
pas mais ces créations répondaient à des
besoins opérationnels liés à l'émergence
de nouvelles technologies pouvant
attirer des partenaires possibles idve
cette fois-ci ingénierie développement
véhicule électrique a été créé au
démarrage de l'activité nouvelle le
véhicule électrique le regroupement de
l'ingénierie du véhicule dédié à 100% au
projet du véhicule à zéro émission de
CO2 au sein d'une seule et même entité
faisait sens en outre pour le véhicule
électrique la création d'une société
devait permettre de créer une dynamique
plus forte pour répondre aux engagements
pris dans le cadre du Grenel de
l'environnement à titre d'exemple
Renault via idve s'est engagé dans un
partenariat stratégique avec le
Commissariat à l'énergie atomique en
2010 sur le développement de batteries
innovantes pour véhicules électriques et
plus largement sur la mobilité durable
quant à Airdream ce qui veut dire
Renault Direction de la recherche et des
études avancées et des matériaux elle a
été créée pour regrouper l'ensemble des
activités de recherche fondamentale du
groupe pour avoir une meilleure
visibilité et une meilleure
planification des coûts de ces activités
et pour développer des partenariats
publics privés je viens d'évoquer la
création récente de filial il convient
par ailleurs de souligner que 85 % des
société du groupe Reno génère du crédit
d'impôt recherche depuis plus de 15 ans
et elles ont plus de 20 ans d'exist
seul les deux sociétés que j'ai
mentionné idve et Airdream ont été
créées en 2009 le montant des dépenses
éligibles au cire de ces deux entités
représente 16 % du montant total des
dépenses éligibles du groupe les
dépenses idve et Airdream élgi auir sont
orienté à la baisse ces créations de
filiales ont été réalisées en toute
transparence vis-à-vis des autorités
fiscal de l'AMF et des organisations
syndicales du groupe elles sont tout à
fait légales et ne contreviennent à
aucun texte fiscal elles ont toutes fait
l'objet de contrôle depuis leur création
contrôle qui n'ont jamais donné lieu à
aucun redressement dernier point sur
lequel il me semble important d'apporter
certaines clarifications il s'agit de
l'absence de personnel dans les filiales
que je viens de citer en effet l'absence
de personnel dans ces trois filiales a
récemment été mise en avant comme étant
un signe d'un montage destiné à éluder
l'impôt et il n'en est rien nous
rappelons que le personnel de idvu était
localisé précisément dans IDV
jusqu'en 2009 et que le transfert du
personnel de idvu vers Renault SAS a été
fait en 2009 et ce pour des raisons
sociales avant tout et managériales
évoqué en 2009 l'absence de personnel
dans idvu est donc totalement
anacronique par ailleurs le fait de
centraliser chez Renault SAS une part
importante du personnel du groupe
Renault en France et les mettre à
disposition de ces filiales est une
organisation commune très répandue au
sein du groupe y compris pour les
filiales réalisant peu ou pas de
dépenses de Red de nombreuses activités
d'ingénierie ou industrielle du groupe
Renault ont été filialisées au cours des
dernières années le personnel a été mise
à disposition de ces filiales par
Renault SAS sans que cela n'ait le
moindre lien avec une éventuelle
optimisation du cire du groupe parmi la
trentaine de filiales opérationnelles du
groupe renaoult seul deux fonctionnent
avec du personnel spécifique il s'agit
de MCA à maobug et de sauab à bâtille
l'intégralité des autres entités du
groupe sans personnel propre mais avec
du personnel misise à disposition par
Renault SAS c'est ainsi le cas pour
toutes les usines Flin doué Souville
pour ne citer que celle-ci le
regroupement du personnel du groupe
Renault que ce soit en matière
d'ingénierie ou de fabrication au niveau
de notre société principale Renault SAS
s'explique par deux principales raisons
le souhait d'abord d'améliorer le climat
social au sein du groupe et de garantir
au maximum au salariés basés en France
les mêmes avantages sociaux
deuxièmement c'est aussi pour des
raisons opérationnelles et pour
permettre plus de souplesse dans la
gestion des effectifs et dans leur
affectation aux différentes activités
des groupes du groupe cette gestion
centrale au niveau de Renault SAS des
effectifs et même un souhait des
partenaires sociaux elle est protectrice
des intérêts des salariés et n'a rien à
voir avec un éventuel montage fiscal
destiné à optimiser le cire pour preuve
cette organisation est également
déployée dans nos usines de fabrication
française que j'ai cité don don la
plupart réalise peu de cire maintenant
la stratégie de Renault en matière de
Red le groupe Renault 10e constructeur
mondial dispose de C centres de
recherche dans le monde en France avec
le Technocentre au Brésil en Corée en
Inde et en Roumanie en dépit de
l'attractivité de ces quatre centres
basés à l'international tant pour la
compétence de leurs ingénieurs que pour
leur structure des coûpts le groupe a
fait le choix de maintenir et de faire
prospérer en France 75 % de sa rdé
mondiale dans ce dans ce contexte le
cire est un facteur essentiel de la
compétitivité du coût des de l'ingénieur
en France alors que le coût de la
recherche française et la deuxème plus
élevée au monde après les États-Unis le
cire améliore la compétitivité de la Red
et de l'industrie française de ce fait
il concourt à rendre le coût de Red
raisonnable et acceptable par rapport à
celui d'autres pays et permet le
maintien et le développement de l'outil
industriel en France depuis le début de
la crise en 2008 c'est à partir c'est en
partie grâce au cire que le groupe renao
présent sur tous les continents a pu
maintenir l'essentiel de ses efforts de
recherche et de développement en France
par ailleurs entre 2008 et 2015 la
recherche fondamentale a pu continuer à
croître grâce au cire ce dernier a
permis d'éviter le Class la le classique
la classique coupure des budgets de
recherche fondamental en période de
crise à titre d'exemple le nombre de
doctorants est resté stable à 100
personnes durant cette période en outre
30 nouveaux doctorants bénéficient
chaque année des bourses des conventions
industrielles de formation par la
recherche CIFRE mise en place par
l'association nationale recherche
technologie ANRT Renaud a pu lancer un
important plan d'embauche en France dans
le cadre du plan de compétitivité
annoncé en février dernier comme déjà
évoqué il se traduira par l'embauche dès
cette année de 500 personnes en red en
France et enfin Renault travaille avec
plus de 100 sous-traitants ou partenaire
de recherche situé en France 78
organismes privés et 47 organismes
publics le montant d'action de Red
sous-traité en France est supérieur à
300 millions d'euros sur ces 300
millions d'euros seul 12 millions
entrent dans le calcul de l'assiette de
Red éligible au cire en raison du
plafonnement des dépenses de
sous-traitance cependant tous ces points
n'auraient pas de sens s'il ne venait en
s'il ne venait pas en soutien des grands
projets de Red de Renault outre le
développement des gammes toujours plus
innovantes allant de la petite citatine
au véhicules utilitaires en passant par
les 44 je citerai quatre quatre
programmes emblématique de Renault le
véhicule électrique zéro émission au
contraire du véhicule hybride avec une
gamme complète de quatre véhiculle tzizo
fluence et Kango vendu partout dans le
monde le véhicule connecté avec les
innovations comme Airlink 2 classé
numéro 1 des systèmes connectés etolable
la voiture pour tous consommant moins de
2 l au 100ang kilomè et qui faisait
partie des 34 plans de reconquête pour
une nouvelle France industrielle
présenté en septembre 2013 par le
Président de la République etolab a même
atteint un une consommation de 1 L au
100 km ou encore l'hybride Loste qui va
permettre de faire bénéficier de cette
technologie au plus grand nombre dans la
droite ligne de la gamme d'AIA qui est
un un succès mondial plus de 500 projets
de Red éligibles au cire sont décrits
dans le détail à la disposition de
l'administration et du ministère de
l'Éducation nationale de l'Enseignement
supérieur et de la Recherche ces
dossiers mettent à contribution plus de
700 personnes chir Rono pour leur
rédaction sur le milliard 500 millions
d'euros investis en red par Renault en
France seul 777 millions sont éligibles
au cire soit un peu plus de 50 % de la
Red française totale en outre sur ces
777 millions d'euros 400 millions sont
plafonnés et donc éligibles à une
contribution sire réduite de 5 %
la question du coût du travail en France
et sa perte de compétitivité est un
sujet connu de tous j'ai sous les yeux
un tableau que vous connaissez sans
doute il est réalisé il n'est pas
réalisé par Renault mais par
l'association nationale recherche
technologie celui-ci figure dans les
réponses écrites au questionnaires de la
commission
d'enquête il compare le coût de la RD
français à celui d'autres pays et montre
comment le cire permet de l'améliorer à
la lecture de ces chiffres le cire
permet de réduire de 11 % le le coût de
l'ingénierie en France ce coût est
intégré dans notre équation dans nos
équations économiques c'est un paramètre
dans les décisions d'arbitrage interne
relatif à la localisation au sein des
différents centres de recherche de notre
groupe des projets de Red du fait du
plafonnement de l'assiette pour les
grandes entreprises à 100 million
d'euros l'impact de la baisse du coût du
travail imputable auire est inférieur
pour celle-ci au taux moyen de 18 %
estimé par la NRT certains ont pu
avancer que les dépenses de recherche du
groupe était orienté à la baisse or il
n'en est rien et je tiens à rétablir la
vérité en vous donnant quelques chiffres
qui contredisent cette affirmation
pendant la période de crise de 2008 à
2009 Renault a fait le choix de
préserver le montant de sa RD le groupe
n'a cessé de l'augmenter depuis passant
de 1illard 870 millions 870 millions
d'euros à 2 mliards 30 millions d'euros
entre 2010 et 2014 soit une progression
de 8,3 %. autre point sur lequel je
souhaite insister le portefeuille de
propriété intellectuelle du groupe est
entièrement détenu par Renault SAS
entité française à ce titre Renault SAS
a déposé en 2014 plus de 600 brevets en
France soit une hausse constante depuis
2008 et un doublement depuis 2010 ceci
place Renault dans le trio de tête des
entreprises innovantes en France par
ailleurs il convient de noter que
Renault SAS ou ses filiales française
réalise pour nos partenaires étrangers
Nissan demler Fiat et general motor de
nombreux travaux de RD dans les domaines
de moteur des moteurs du véhicule
électrique et des véhicules utilitaires
ce sont ces domaines où les compétences
de Renault sont largement reconnues et
appréciés ces travaux de RD facturés par
Renault SAS à ses partenaires étrangers
pour la seule année 2014 ont représenté
un montant supérieur à 260 millions
d'euros la gestion patrimoniale par le
groupe Renault de sa propriété
intellectuel est entièrement organisé en
France les brevets et le savoir-faire du
du groupe sont donc entièrement détenus
par Renault SAS en France nous n'avons
pas de patent box aux Pays-Bas ou aux
Bermudes par exemple le groupe Renoult
est une entreprise citoyenne soucieuse
du respect de ses obligations fiscales
vis-à-vis de l'État français les
redevances rapatriées en France par
Renault SAS au titre des concessions à
ces filiales étrangères de cette période
de de cette propriété intellectuelle
représente environ 300 millions d'euros
tous les ans comme nous l'avions euh
évoqué précédemment outre ces redevances
Renault SAS facture à ses partenaires
plus de 260 millions d'euros de frais de
Red tous les ans au titre de la seule
gestion de sa RD le groupe Renault
rapatrie donc tous les ans en France 560
millions d'euros de base fiscale
pleinement imposable à 38 % plus une
CVAE de 1,5 %. vous en conviendrez on ne
peut pas parler d'une optimisation
fiscale agressive ces 560 millions
d'euros de base fiscale imposable au
niveau de Renault SAS sont à prendre en
compte au même titre que le S dans
l'équation fiscale de la recherche en
France le cire incite les entreprises à
réaliser de la RD en France plutôt que à
la à la délocalisé hors de France cette
Red est de fait détenu par Renault en
France et génère une base imposable en
France il s'agit là d'un écosystème
particulièrement vertueux Renault assume
en conscience la responsabilité
particulière qui découle de
l'attribution par la collectivité
nationale du mécanisme du crédit d'impôt
recherche de ce point de vue Renault et
plus que jamais une belle industrie
inscrite dans le patrimoine et dans
l'imaginaire de notre pays et de nos
concitoyens une entreprise citoyenne en
pointe en matière de RD de localisation
de sa RD une entreprise performante qui
embauche notamment des ingénieurs en
France 1000 CDI et 1000 contrats
d'apprentissage cette année en
conclusion grâce à l'Arsenal m en place
par le législateur français aux
arbitrages du management du groupe Rono
et au talent et à
l'investissement et à l'investissement
de plus de de presè presque 120000
collaborateurs de notre entreprise je
tiens à vous préciser que 75 % de la
recherche de Renault est faite en France
pays dans lequel le coût du travail
reste pourtant élevé la propriété
intellectuelle réalisée à l'étranger est
entièrement détenue par Renault SAS en
France tous les brevets et savoir-faire
appartiennent à Renault SAS en France
les facturations diverses apportent à
Renault sas entre 500 et 600 millions
d'euros par an de base fiscale en France
les 2/3 de notre dépenses de nos
dépenses éligibles au cire sont plafonné
à 5 % 85 % des sociétés éligibles au
cire du groue Renault existent depuis
plus de 20 ans et Renault enfin
s'interdit tout schéma d'optimisation
fiscale de sa propriété intellectuelle
tel les patteron box ou autres
domiciliation à taux d'imposition
favorable dois-je ajouter que si Ren
recherchz le bénéfice d'un quelconque
effet d'auè d'une une délocalisation de
la RD associée à une gestion fiscale
plus optimisante de son porte feuille de
Red générerait des économies sociales et
fiscales sans commune mesure avec les
gains que représente le cire et est un
contestable cor Rena s'est toujours
interdit d'adopter une telle stratégie
en effet la recherche et le
développement compte parmi les activités
les plus faciles à délocaliser car elle
ne nécessite au fond de ressources
autres que l'intelligence et le talent
des ingénieurs cette intelligence et ce
talent ne sont pas les seuls apanages de
notre pays qui n'en a pas le monopole de
compétences techniqu et scientifique
je vous remercie de votre attention
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et moi je vous remercie d'un
exposé
exhaustif ce qui fait que ça va réduire
quand même le nombre des questions que
nous avions
préparé dire quand même deux trois
choses d'abord le président de la
commission d'enquête il organise ses
travaux comme il le souhaite et surtout
il contue de l'environnement alors moi
j'ai souhaité personn ement que le
reportage soit retraduit pour une raison
simple c'est qu'un certain nombre de
membres de commission enquête ne l'ont
pas vu donc une partie de votre exposé
aurait été mal compris si on avait pas
eu bon et puis euh quand même les
capitaine d'industrie que vous êtes
quand même vous êtes quand même habitué
quand même à subir d'autres chocs que
celui que vous avez mal vécu ici au
Sénat en rappelant quand même que
Pujadas doit être 5 millions de
spectateurs ici que ça ça ne fait jamais
qu'une quinzaine en plus
vous dire aussi que puisque on est là
aussi pour se dire les choses le la non
réaction à un pareil reportage nous on
n' pas bon on est quand même nombreux à
avoir dans la commissions d'enquête très
majoritairement pensé que tout ça avait
beaucoup
d'affabulationg à ce qu'est
Renault alors
le moi je peux vous dire que les dégâts
sur le terrain d'une parmission sont
réel hein dans ma brave commune je peux
dans la banlieue parisienne où on roule
plutôt en Renault qu'and ve qu' voiture
allemande je peux vous dire que j'ai eu
des commentaires sur ce qui ont été fait
qui sont désagréable l'impact est réel
et euh il était difficile aussi pour
nous d'ignorer eu comme vous le dites
superbement nous quand on dit euh des
choses totalement inexactes on n pas
l'habitude de polémiquer pour nous c'est
difficile de d'ignorer parce queon nous
en a parlé même nos collègues en ont
parlé euh nous travaillons sur ce sujet
depuis 4 mois la rapporteur est en train
de finaliser le
rapport pour d'ici 3 semaines alors de
voir ce reportage arrivé en plein milieu
de nos travaux on s'est quand même posé
un nombre de questions naturellement bon
tout ceci n'est pas totalement innocent
on n'est pas on n'est pas stupide mais
je pense que en plus une société côté en
bourse sur des pareilles allégations
elle peut pas trop se permettre de dire
je répond pas ce type d'argument et
nous-même on a été surpris parce que en
réalité il a comm on aurait dit bon on
aurait noté queil y avait une émission
pu un communiqué bon voilà et je pense
qu'on vous donne l'occasion aussi de
remettre les choses en place d'une façon
sérieuse et je
dirais avec vraiment des arguments et
avec
vraiment et votre exposé a répondu à 80
% de nos questions qui sont des
questions légitimes alors maintenant je
vais donner la parole à Monsieur gascon
à Ban voilà
il est pas obligé d'être aussi long mais
s'il a des choses ajouter qu' les ajoute
monsieur le Président mais madame la
rapporteur je pense que l'exposé était
assez clair moi j'attends c'est des
questions qui n'ont pas été peut-être
abordé dans les dans l'exposé je pense
que c'est ça qui peut intéresser pas
répéter à nouveau les même les mêmes
chiffres les mêmes
détails madame
DOD non je crois que l'exposé a été
assez complet comme vous l'avez
mentionné effectivement je serai là pour
appuyer mes collègues pour répondre aux
questions bon alors madame la rapporteur
les questions vont se passer comme ça la
rapporteur pose des questions après
l'ensemble des membres de la commission
pose puis vous répondez euh oui merci
Monsieur pour cet exposé qui nous
importe Moutte précision j'avais en tant
que rapporteur bien entendu reçu la
réponse de Renault mais je suis tenue au
secret fiscal comme vous le savez donc
c'est bien aussi que nous puissions
avoir ce moment d'échange alors moi je
voudrais vous demander une précision
parce que juste toujours sur cette
question des de ces fameuses filiales
moi j'ai bien noté queun était créée en
1966 et deux deux en 2009 mais vous nous
dites que donc l'absence de personnel
d'idve et de
Airdream n'est qu'apparente et que il y
a un personnel qui mis à disposition que
ça a correspondu à une exigen
opérationnelles de l'entreprise et vous
nous avez décrit succintement en quoi
consistait en quoi ces exigences
opérationnelles est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire qui est réputé assumer
juridiquement les les salaires de ces
entités et quel est le niveau de fond
propre pour chacune d'entre elles euh je
voudrais aussi profiter de vous avoir
sous la M si je puis dire pour que vous
nous disiez peut-être si vous avez subi
des contrôles fiscaux y compris comment
ça s'est passé s'il y a eu des des
redressements et cetera parce que c'est
une question qui a été récurrente chez
nous parce que c'est une question qu'on
voudrait sur laquelle on voudrait porter
des amélior des améliorations et ma
dernière question parce que vous nous
avez vraiment donné beaucoup beaucoup de
précision ça va un peu vite donc
peut-être ça sera une une précision que
vais vous demander mais est-ce que vous
pouvez nous indiquer quelle est la
valeur des droits incorporels issu de la
recherche dans le bilan du groupe quels
sont les revenus comptabilisés à ce
titre dans le compte de résultat et
quels sont les revenus correspondant
inclus dans votre dans votre résultat
fiscal en France s'il vous plaît j'en
aurais terminé monsieur le Président bon
très bien Madame rapporteur je crois que
va mieux y aller auditeur après auditeur
parce qu'à la fin c'est voilà c'est un
peu compliqué Monsieur le Directeur
Financier alors je vais je vais essayer
de vous avez beaucoup de de de questions
si s'il y a des points de détail et des
chiffres que je ne voudrais pas vous les
envoyz par écr vous les envoyez par
écrit en tout cas je peux déjà vous
décrire puisque vous avez une question
aussi de de de de compréhension de du
fonctionnement du du groupe Reno al il
faut faire juste un tout petit peu
d'histoire et ça remonte à la Régie
quand on était une régie une régie n'a
un peu par définition pas de bilan et
donc c'est une structure un petit peu un
petit
peu unique et atypique dans le monde
Industri et quand Renault a été
privatisé donc c'est devenu une société
anonyme et il y a eu le souci à ce
moment-là de maintenir ce qu'on a pu
appeler un statut donc les employés se
voyaient mal tout d'un coup
devenir membbrre d'une d'une entité ou
d'une filiale qui soit pas Renault et
donc on a créé donc Renault SAS donc qui
est une société unique en France et qui
possède un certain nombre de filiales
opération
toutes nos usines par exemple euh comme
nos bureaux d'études qui sont des
essentiellement des société de moyens
euh une usine fabrique des voitures mais
elle a pas d'autres vocation donc c'est
un centre de cût un bureau d'étude et un
petit peu de la même façon affecté de
ressources mises à disposition par
Renault SAS exactement comme des
ouvriers dans une usine ou des
ingénieurs donc dans un dans un bureau
d'étude donc ces frais sont refacturés à
ces filiales donc elles sont elles ont
un compte de résultat un bilan euh mais
tout ceci en en consolidé fait que on
arrive à préserver les droits des
salariés et tous les avantages qu'ils
avaient en étant personnel du groupe
Renault sous un seul sous un
seul chapeau euh et ceci pour tout tous
toute la législation sociale et tout
l'animation sociale du du groupe que ce
soit la les mutuels les avantages enfin
le personnel est entièrement euh sous
une seule une seule société euh donc ce
sont des sociétés qui ne sont pas du
tout fictives euh et plus donc comme je
l'ai dit on en a créé deux uniquement en
2009 qui était donc pour le véhicule
électrique et l'autre pour rassembler
notre recherche fondamentale et là je
laisserai peut-être mon collègue
monsieur Gascan à Belland vous vous
décrire un petit peu cette ce que fait
cette société mais euh on avait euh
l'intention et on a des partenariats
avec des souvent des sociétés étrangères
et quand on est
en partenariat l'usine de Sandouville
vous le savez peut-être fabrique des
véhicules utilitaires pour Renault pour
Nissan pour General Motors bientôt pour
Fiat qui a décidé de venir s'associer à
nous et donc le développement de ces
véhicules est fait en France par cette
société
idvu donc par du personnel Renault qui
est mis à sa disposition et donc qui qui
développe pour le compte de de tiers et
quand je dis qu'on refacture à ses
partenaires un montant élevé de presque
300 millions d'euros par an c'est le
développement c'est le travail des
ingénieurs français qui est refacturé à
Fiat à Daimler merc à à Nissan pour le
développement de véhicules qui seront
ensuite vendus sur leur propre marque
euh un petit peu partout dans le dans le
monde et cette société donc ça nous
permet de localiser par
activité le véhicule utilitaire nous
avons des partenariats et avec le
véhicule électrique comme là aussi il
s'agissait d'ouvrir à des partenariats
j'en ai décrit un avec le CEA donc le
Commissariat à l'énergie atomique et
puis d'autres dans le monde des
batteries et de la de ce de cette
technologie là aussi quand il s'agit de
de facturer ou de de refacturer nos
frais de Red d'avoir une société de
moyens est une une façon commode et
pratique d'isoler cette activité du
reste du groupe renao alors le statut
juridique je je vais je vais vous le
vérifier je pense que ce sont des
sociétés de moyens en tout cas elles
sont complètement transparentes elles
sont publi enfin elles sont publiées
dans nos rapports et dans nos documents
de référence et on va vous rechercher
les trois questions de chiffres que vous
vouliez des droits incorporels enfin ce
qu'on a au
bilan tout est sur sur SAS Renault SAS
porte la
totalité de comme je le disais de tous
les brevets tout tous les actifs et tout
ce qui est corporel et incorporel est
porté par Renault SAS et le taux de
capitalisation est de l'ordre de 42
%. tout est tout est entièrement
centralisé
euh alors il y a dans votre dans le
questionnaire qu'on vous a envoyé il y a
un organigramme qui qui montre le la
l'organisation le patri du groupe et
donc qui devrait pouvoir répondre à
cette question mais on va vous la on va
vous le détailler mais peut-être un mot
de de la recherche fondamental de oui
simplement aussi pour clarifier pourquoi
cette cette organisation des ressources
d'ingénierie ou des ressources de
recherche et et développement en général
t les sociétés modernes aujourd'hui sont
des structures d'organisation
matricielle c'est-à-dire dans un côté on
a des axes d'activités qui sont des
projets finalement et d'autre côté on a
des métiers des fonctions qui sont des
spécialistes techniques et donc le
projet et dans l'axe vertical on les
fait en groupant des ressources qui sont
spécialisé dans différents métiers en
fonction de la nature du projet et
clairement dans le passés c'était une
des évolutions que l'entreprise il a il
a fait pour justement pour optimiser et
sa sa performance sa performance de
résultat c'était eu et la ressource
était un peu éparpillée en silo euh
découpé dans des des zones étanches
chose qui faisait que certaines
activités parfois ils étaient à la
baisse et donc les les ressources
étaient mal engagé et par contre il
apparaissait des nouvelles domaines
technique où clairement on avait besoin
des pompur des ressources et eu la
flexibilité à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise était pas suffisant c'est
une raison fondamentale pour laquelle on
a décidé des grouper et T ces ressources
dans dans dans une sur le mê chapeau à
la au à l'objet basiquement de Flex
d'avoir plus de flexibilité et en
fonction des de la charge des différents
projets pouvoir basculer la ressource
d'un côté à l'autre par contre il est
essentiel maintenir l'identité des
activités l'identité des activités de
nature très différent par exemple quand
on a lancé les les programme électrique
c'est une activité complètement nouvelle
dans l'entreprise il faut les créer pas
ement des métiers mais des des des
programmes qui n'avaient rien à voir
avec ce qu'on avait fait auparavant et
faire des partenariats avec des sociétés
de recherche extérieur aussi avec des
des partenaires commerciaux et de ce
côté-là il faut avoir une gestion
clairement indépendant clairement
individualisée clairement visible et
explicable face à à nos partenaires et
face à l'in l'entreprise quielle est
vraiment la la dépense à réaliser et
l'effort technique porter donc c'est
fondamental entendre cette structure
matricielle de toutes les organisations
d'ingénierie actuelle et qui permettent
justement sur le même chapeau pouvoir
faire des des différentes activités
d'une façon
optimisée
vaspard monsieur le Président Mesdames
Messieurs vous avez prêté serment
ce qui veut dire
que ce que nous avons entendu on peut
considérer que c'est votre
vérité mais un peu aussi la vérité du
groupe je serais comme mon collègue
président un peu
atterré de voir qu'il a pas eu de
réaction quand on voit à quel
point cette émission a pu faire des
dégâts pour vous
d'abord
pour le
dispositif qui a été mis en place par
les gouvernements antérieurs et confirmé
par le gouvernement actuel et puis je
vais même vous dire ici au niveau de
notre commission puisque comme l'a
rappelé le Président nous y travaillons
depuis plus de 4
mois que les uns et les autres ont
commencé à se forger une opinion euh
certaine et qu'au moment où on se forge
une opinion certaine on se retrouve avec
cette émission de télévision qui
euh peut être amené à à remettre en
cause éventuellement ce que l'opinion
qu'on s'est
forgé alors au travers de ce que vous
nous avez dit et je rappelle je rappelle
que vous l'avez dit sous cerment et pour
moi ça a une grande importance il est
évident que j'ai entendu en ce qui me
concerne à titre personnel ce que vous
nous avez
exposé
je l'ai entendu j'ai entendu vous étiez
sur 2,3 milliards de d'investissement en
matière de
recherche qu'il y en avait
1,5 sur le territoire
français que vous bénéficiez de 143
million d'euros au niveau du cire et que
vous rappeliez ici en
France une un volume financier de 540
560 million d'euros à 38 % d'impôt ce
qui paye quasiment le
cire j'ai envie de
dire cette émission fait flop flop
flop sauf que vous êtes ici devant 10 ou
15 personnes qui vont être amenés à
signer ou non et faire des commentaires
ou non sur un rapport on verra on en
verra le
contenu et que l'émission c'est devant
des millions de
téléspectateurs et je vais même aller
plus loin j'espère que c'est pas
orchestré voilà j'espère que ce n'est
pas
orchestré j'espère que cette commission
de de travail que nous nous avons mené
depuis 4 mois
euh certains ne sont pas en train
d'essayer de
forcer la main si j'ose dire de ceux et
celles qui ont à signer un
rapport
euh car ça serait
absolument désastreux au niveau de la
démocratie et de ce que on peut en
attendre ce serait même scandaleux je
dis même ce serait
scandaleux mais je le dis et je
signe c'est la raison pour laquelle je
pense qu'il faudrait que nous entendions
monsieur le
Président le président de France
Télévision parce qu'on ne peut pas
impunément lancer le prob et sur des
dispositifs et sur des
entreprises dans une période où notre
pays a besoin à la fois de ces grandes
entreprises et à la fois de tout le
tissu PME PMI qui permet qui permet de
maintenir au mieux même si c'est
difficile l'emploi
je tiens à dire Madame la rapporteur
même si ça vous
gêne et
j'iraiis j'irai jusqu'au bout si vous
voulez bien de mon
propos je voudrais vous poser une
question
puisque l'objectif c'est effectivement
de poser une
question je voudrais vous poser une
question vous avez dit effectivement que
vous aviez
maintenu les effectifs en matière de
recherche mais que vous êtes en train de
les augmenter
je voudrais que vous nous disiez
toujours sous
serment si le dispositif du cire
n'existait
pas on a déjà entendu j'ai posé cette
question déjà à d'autres y compris des
des collègues à vous euh si le
dispositif du cire n'existait pas est-ce
que aujourd'hui vous seriez en situation
d'augmenter les effectif en matière de
recherche et développement sur chez
Renault ou est-ce qu'il a été un
déclencheur pour vous permettre
aujourd'hui d'augmenter vos effectifs en
matière de recherche et
développement euh
sur je pense que pour le reste euh bon
c'est contexte général
euh mais je je je dis très clairement
que sur ce sur ce dossier Renault euh
madame la rapporteur euh travaille tout
à fait objectif
il des choses que
je
voilà bien alors vous avez la parole
monsieur Thorman
bien merci je vais essayer de de
répondre peut-être par trois trois axes
différents à votre
question
la la que le que la recherche et le
développement se fasse en France ou
illeur n'est pas déterminante dans la
décision de mener à bien ou non un
projet euh on a euh la recherche c'est
des ingénieurs c'est mon collègue ici à
droite et rien de plus il des quelques
prototypes mais c'est rien de plus et
ceci vous pouvez le faire n'importe où
dans le monde il y a rien de plus fluide
euh que la matière grise et on na pas le
monopole en tout cas dans notre groupe
de cette de ce savoir-faire en France
puisqu'on a aussi dans
des bureaux d'études à l'étranger les
mêmes compétences et les mêmes et les
mêmes capacités donc il en vient à votre
question de savoir mais quel est
l'arbitrage que vous faites finalement
qui fait que tel projet est développé en
France ou ou ailleurs alors la recherche
fondamentale
ensuite on a néanmoins un effet de
d'expérience et de masse critique en
France puisque c'est notre origine et
notre euh notre nos moyens ont été
concentrés ici depuis depuis bien
longtemps mais l'importance du cire a
fait que là où la France aujourd'hui se
place le deuxème pays le plus cher
derrière les États-Unis le deuxème pays
le plus cher derrière les États-Unis est
très loin devant des pays très voisins
qui peuvent-être l'Allemagne ou
l'Angleterre ou l'Espagne n nous avons
des beaucoup d'infrastructures
industrielles le cire remet la France
dans un pleoton
un petit peu le milieu du pleloton ce
qui nous permet ensuite de faire un
calcul économique par rapport à un
projet et de se dire en fait ça remet
nos forces françaises en en concurrence
ou en tout cas à pied d'égalité avec no
nos bureaux d'études à à l'étranger et
donc ça c'est une dimension et vous
ensuite de là tirez bah le projet est-ce
qu'il a vocation a tre essentiellement
européen ou est-ce que c'est un projet
qui qui est un un véhicule qui va
être pour l'Asie ou pour l'Amérique du
Sud ou l'Inde où le notre président
vient de lancé par exemple un véhicule
très innovant en Inde pour le marché
indien et qui est très spécifique à des
mais il a été développé en France et et
ça il faut le savoir le ce véhicule dont
la presse va parler aujourd'hui c'est le
Technocentre de de Renault qui qui l'a
développé quand on dit que peut-être
qu'il viendrait un jour en Europe parce
qu'on a vu circuler sur bah oui il y a
eu des prototypes qui ont dû circuler
sur des routes pour pour les validations
et donc les décisions dans nos décisions
économiques on on regarde ces coûts
et le le cire nous permet d'être dans
dans la course alors écrire un scénario
et vous dire quelle aurait été la
décision prise sur le développement d'un
projet si nous n'avions pas le cire euh
elle c'est peut-être pas facile à à le
dire en plus sous serment parce que je
voudrais pas vous dire quelque chose qui
qui serait inexact mais euh ça ça
donnerait une à l'équation économique un
biais que nous n'avons pas grâce au cire
euh et ça ça c'est un premier élément de
de réponse je crois que l'embauche des
500 ingénieurs qu'on a décidé on a signé
en 2013 un accord de compétitivité en
France et cet accord de compétitivité
avec nos partenaires sociaux avait comme
contrepartie un certain nombre
d'engagements pris par le la direction
qui chercher donc à localiser en France
des
productions étrangères notamment à fin
ou encore à Sandouville ou Fiat va venir
fabriquer une voiture à Sandouville
Nissan àin et ceci a fait que
l'ingénierie a été donc sollicité pour
des projets qui n'auraient pas existé
autrement euh et le fait d'avoir le cire
nous a permis et donc d'avoir un coût
compétitif de leur ou d'un des talents
français nous a permis de répondre euh à
euh Nissan ou à Fiat ou encore à à
Mercedes euh parce que pour eux c'est
encore plus facile que pour nous ils ont
des bureaux d'études partout et dans des
pays très différents euh et donc euh il
n'avait aucune il n'auraiit trouvé aucun
avantage euh économique à a demandé à
Renault de développer pour leur compte
si si le coût qu'on aurait côté aurait
été non compétitif le fait d'avoir
l'accord de compétitivité et le cire qui
maintient donc un un coût un cout
acceptable pour l'ingénierie nous a
permis de répondre en fait à des appels
d'offre et comme constructeur on s'est
retrouvé quasiment fournisseur puisque
quand on développe pour le compte de
Nissan ou de demler c'est de là et vous
le ctiez on
refacture ceci à ce ce ce travail à ses
partenaires et ça c'est des ce sont des
factures imposables en France donc qui
viennent nourrir la base fiscale
française et sans notre accord de
compétitivité ça aurait été difficile
d'attirer Nissan qui avait le choix
entre fabriquer sa voiture en France ou
en Inde puisqu'elle est aujourd'hui
fabriquée en Inde la Micra elle vient en
France c'est quand même un témoignage je
crois des
deux de bah de ce retour à la
compétitivité de
notre de notre in ingénierie ou Fiat qui
vient euh à Sandouville se joindre à au
projet de du véhicule utilitaire dans
dans et là aussi tout ça c'est développé
par tes équipes je peux je peux
simplement pour vous compléter par
exemple aujourd'hui les activités
d'ingénierie mécanique o vous connaissez
tous bon les moteurs Renault notamment
les moteurs diessel mais aussi des
moteurs essence et puis une gamme des
moteurs hybride moteur électrifié qu'on
est en train de développer aujourd'hui
sont plébiscités par partout nos même
nos compétiteur on va dire et à tel
point qu'aujourd'hui l'activité
d'ingéerie mécanique Onon déveloe qu'on
fait ici en France
et comporte à peu près 30 % 30 %
l'activité pardon il est pour les
comptes de nos partenaires 30 % euh
qu'on aurait pas si on n'était pas
compétitif et 30 % c'est énorme je peux
vous le dire c'est énorme et ça permet
en même temps de pouvoir se payir du
développement des nouvell technologie
pour donner une continuité pour soutenir
cette activité là et notre vocation et
notre volonté clairement c'est de faire
de la France et notamment de nos de nos
équipes en France vraiment la base
technologique de ce qui sont les futur
plateforme automobile vous avez dans
l'automobile il y a les pour dire comme
ça le contenu technique puis ce qu'on
voit extérieurement la carrosserie c'est
une espèce depau qu'on met sur la
plateforme mais la vraie valeur ajoutée
la vraie savoir-faire et la vraie
technologie il est dans la plateforme et
de ce côté-là on a l'intention de
pouvoir poursuivre ces développement ici
et de servir pour le dire comme ça
toutes les autres marchés sous C B
technique et puis pouvoir développer des
applications qui c'est ni plus ni moins
déjà la finition du travail euh commencé
ici si si je peux me permettre monsieur
monsieur le sénateur si je peux juste me
permettre un complément pour répondre
définitivement j'espère à votre question
l'ingénierie dans l'industrie automobile
tire tout le reste c'est-à-dire que si
vous avez une ingénierie compétitive en
cout
euh vous arrivez plus facilement à
localiser à nourrir vos usines à
fabriquer localement euh puisque le
développement euh et et un peu détaché
du lieu de vente mais quand vous avez un
développement qui est fait qui
rassemble les techniques que vous avez
employé sur plusieurs gammes de
véhicules vous avez des effets d'échelle
de partage et de plus en plus de
technologies sont communes aux voitures
l'électrification c'est la même qu'elle
soit petite ou grande ce sont les mêmes
composants qui sont utilisés et donc
pour nous ce qui est fondamental c'est
l'amont donc on part tout à fait de la
recherche fondamentale qui se ensuite se
se décline en en recherche d'application
et et c'est ce qui tire la compétitivité
du groupe et c'est pour nous c'est
fondamental que ce soit en France que la
France soit compétitive c'est c'est là
où on a le plus de ressources
oui merci président d'abord merci
président d'avoir organisé cette
audition je crois qu'elle était
importante et je vrais vous remercier de
la clarté de de votre présentation tout
à l'heure euh il était effectivement je
partage qu'à dit mon collègue il était
important de de vous
entendre néanmoins j'aurais deux
questions euh qui rest don qui m'éloigne
de du débat polémique que je trouve que
je qualifie de la même manière je
reviens sur le le vrai objet de notre
mission d'enquête commission d'enquête
c'est un euh vous avez fait état suite
au au cire de 600 brevets déposé ce qui
est
important et j'aurais deux questions à
ce niveau-là la première c'est donc
déposé en France j'insiste là-dessus
oui non mais c'est important votre
réponse elle est très importante parce
que dans les d'autres auditions on a pu
voir que parfois il y avait du cire où
les brevets n'étaient pas déposés en
France donc ma question vous allez voir
la suite c'est bon il y en a 600 qui
sont déposés en France est-ce que vous
en déposez étranger à partir des crédits
du
cire et deuxème question la dernière les
brevet une fois déposés la
production alors il y a des brevets qui
sont déposés parfois qui ne rent pas
forcément en production on est bien
d'accord je suis dans l'entre monde
économique aussi mais mais néanmoins
est-ce que vous pouvez donner nous
éclairer et nous donner un peu la
part d'exécution et de mise en
production de ces 600 brevets par
exemple qui ont été déposés en
France s'ils sont produits dans
l'Hexagone ou ailleurs bon la première
réponse c'est c'est oui basilement les
99 % des brevés ils sont déposés en
France pe avoir en nouek je peux pas
vous préciser en nouek un peu qui reste
dans dans son territoire pour une
dispositif très spécifique à une marchée
comm ça peut la rousie la rousie par
exemple pour des des des ultra basse
température et cetera
mais la réponse est oui toutes les les
vra sont ici alors après combien ils
sont lesécuté quand vous avez la
production de brevet ça génère pas
automatiquement toujours des mais euh
pour vous donner un chiffre ça fait
quelques années euh peut-être à
l'horizon 2002 ne prenez pas exactement
la les chiffres bon on déposait beaucoup
plus on on déposait même 1000 et par
contre la qualité de ces brvet était
piètre en général il y avait très
beaucoup de brevvés c'était des idées un
peu on va dire trop trop irréalisable et
trop difficile à à faire depuis là on a
fait depuis déjà au moins 10 années et
on a fait un nettoyage complè du système
pour être filtré la qualité des vv
effectivement travaillur sous des vrav
qui pouvaient représenter un atout et un
potentiel vraiment industriel
aujourd'hui les chiffres je pourrais
vous les chercher et vous les envoyer de
combien de Bré il déri il il débauche
finalement dans une application
industrielle c'est beaucoup plus élevé
que dans le passé ceci dit les brebé il
sert aussi à protéger et notre solution
technique c'est pas toujours euh le
brbet pas fait pour développer un
produit tout de suite les brbet aussi
fait pour protéger les solutions je vaux
vous donner un exemple sur Renault et
olab sur les véhicules qu'on a qu'on a
présenté au Salon de l'automobile qui
consomme un litro au on a déposé plus
d'une centaine de BRB alors et ces
centaines de BRB qu'on a déposé une
partie des des des brevet des solutions
qu'on a qu'on a présenté sur Renault Lab
ils vont être appliqués sur la futur
Clio pour vous dire comme ça pas tous
parce que dans les idées dans les BR
déposés il y a des idées vraiment très
en routure impossible à suivre dans
l'immédiate au niveau des faisibilités
industriell on a besoin de faire évoluer
les outils industriel et cetera mais on
protège le fait que lorsque on sera prêt
à pouvoir les appliquer on les applique
en
exclusivité monsieur le sénateur si je
peux aussi puisque derrière votre
question je peux vous dire là aussi
toujours sous serv 100 % de la propriété
intellectuelle de Renault est détenue en
France il y a aucune propriété
intellectuelle détenue à
l'étranger est-ce que tu as une réponse
complète
oui complète la réponse ta question par
non non non j'en
profite si c'est pas indiscret
d'ailleurs je pense pas mais c'est
important pour nous ici en tant qu'élu
dans c'est 600 pour est-ce que vous
pouvez nous donner en
masse la ceux qui sont qui touche plutôt
la sécurité ceux qui touchent plutôt le
domaine de l'économie
d'énergie voyez l'esprit même si vous PZ
mais ça nous intéresserait parce que la
la conséquence
comment non mais oui ils ont déjà
répondu là ils ont répondu pour moi ils
ont R
non c'est clair mais par contre ça
m'intéresserait parce que la
répercussion vous avez compris le sens
parce que ça double répercussion
derrière voir plus donc effectivement si
on peut avoir un peu les les angles
d'attaque sur les les différents
brevets prix que 100 % ou
99,% on va pas on n'est pas était
immatriculé en France mais où sont-ils
réalisés et comment sont perçu les
redevances liées au
brevet en France tout est réalisé en
France ça cé très important pour nous de
savoir clairement ça merci voilà c'était
sa question ouioui c'était votre
question mais j'avais pas bien
compris tu une réponse complète ça
va oui peut-être les
écrire on vous facilite absolument les
découp pas sur quel domaine technique il
porte la V il a aucun
problème madame la rapporteur c'est
c'est encore pire c'est-à-dire que nous
facturons l'étranger pour l'usage de la
propriété intellectuelle en France c'est
toujours c'est la redevance elle revient
en France toujours et les montants sont
dans votre questionnaire par par année
c'est ça ça en fait partie qui attend
depuis un moment oui mais j'écoute avec
intérêt non d'autant plus que une une
question qui se décompose en deux
parties une quantitativement et l'autre
qualitativement mais c'est dans le
prolongement d'ailleurs de l'échange
depuis un instant
euh
question quantitativement vous avez
effectivement parlé de la Recherche
Développement en disant qu'elle se
faisait massivement en France mais sur
plusieurs site il est intéressant pour
nous par rapport au au à la valeur au
coût de la Recherche Développement que
vous puissiez nous donner quels sont les
autres sites
euh Renault dans le monde
euh quelle est l'importance de ces sites
de recherche développement le nombre de
de de chercheurs de personnel qui sont
attachés et puis site par site le coût
puisque effectivement vous avez indiqué
que c'est en France que le coût de la
Recherche Développement est est est le
plus élevé et que le CIR euh contribuit
pour beaucoup si ce n'est à le rendre
plus compétitif en tout cas en atténuer
le coût puisque vous avez indiqué qu'il
était le deuxième coût le plus cher
euh sur le plan international alors ma
deuxième question cette fois-ci sur le
volet qualitatif
euh
vous vous nous avez dit qu'effectivement
vous développiez en France sur cette
recherche développement compte tenu
effectivement de l'amélioration du coût
qui était donné par le C un certain
nombre de développement dans des
casadres des partenariats j'imagine que
ces partenariats ils sont liés aussi à
la qualité de de la Recherche
Développement de de ces pôles de
recherche et là on ça s'inscrit dans des
démarches que vous connaissez bien les
pôles de compétitivité c'est-à-dire
d'essayer de rassembler dans des
filières et j'imagine que si vous
développez le véhicule électrique en
France c'est que vous avez dans ce
domaines là des compétences vous avez
évoqué notamment les partenariats avec
le COA que nous avons rencontré par
ailleurs donc ce sont ces
écosystèmes qui sont importants qui sont
également importants pour nous parce que
si on veut que la recherche
développement la recherche développement
de de bon niveau se développe en France
il faut que ces écosystèmes se
maintiennent alors dans ce voletl est-ce
que vous pouvez peut-être nous donner
plus
d'éléments sur les instituts avec
lesquels vous développez euh certains
programmes là le le collègue vous
demandz à l'instant de vous de nous
donner des précisions sur la nature des
brevets par rapport à certaines
catégories est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner les les instituts avec lesquels
vous vous travaillez la mobilisation euh
des des enseignants du CNRS des
doctorant et autres puisque c'est
également pour nous un élément important
de voir les passerelles les liens qu'il
y a entre le milieu de l'industrie et et
le milieu de la recherche et notamment
celle universitaire voilà donc si vous
voulez cette de deè question sur toutes
les informations que vous pourriez nous
donner qui sont également un élément non
négligeable sur la philosophie de la
recherche développement mais je dirais
la capacité qu'on a de maintenir et
développer cette recherche développement
en
France bien je vais peut-être prendre
votre première question et laisser mon
collègue prendre les les deux suivantes
donc les sites de Renault nous en avons
quatre à
l'étranger en Inde en Roumanie au Brésil
et en Corée du Sud donc là il il s'agit
de bureau d'étude donc de centre de
recherche euh pour vous donner un ordre
de grandeur si la France est étalonnée à
100 l'Inde c'est 25 26 donc c'est un
quart du coup de la de la France avant
cire une fois qu'on
a le le
cire la France se retrouve à peu près
comme le Brésil par
exemple en coup d'ingénieur souvent dans
des pays réputés être à bas coût le coût
de l'ingénieur relatif aux autres
professions et aux autres métiers dans
ces pays-là est relativement peut-être
élevé par rapport à d'autres d'autres
professions donc les écarts sont
moindres que si vous compariez par
exemple le coût d'une
usine en France ou en Espagne ou en
Allemagne ou en Angleterre par rapport à
une usine dans un en Inde là l'écart
serait encore beaucoup plus
important et donc le le cire nous ramène
en tout cas dans notre industrie dans un
un pleoton où on pourrait se on serait
pas très loin de la Grande-Bretagne on
serait à peu près comme comme l'Italie
ou encore le le Brésil et et donc
nettement moins cher le pays le plus
cher au monde c'est ce sont les
États-Unis aujourd'hui qui
attire oui oui alors on a un tableau
qu'on a mis également dans le dans le
questionnaire qu'on pourra vous donner
alors peut-être donc les questions
relatives au pôle de compétitivité le
les instituts avec lesquels on travaille
peut-être certainement vous avez on est
Renault il est il est parti participant
et intégrante de la de la plateforme la
filière automobile et c'est dans ces
cadre là où on développe diverses
programmes qui sont d'intérêt général et
qui son un peu que les des dev vitur des
des dynamiques pour pourousser la
recherche dans l'automobile et notamment
c'est dans ces CADR là qu'on a lancé le
projet des du véhicule des litres au
100ang véhicule consomm des lites au 100
qui était démarré dans les Granel de
l'environnement mais qui était passé
après à la plateforme et et dans la
l'écosystème la plateforme on a à part
de réunir les grands écapentiures qui
qui travaillent avec nous avec nous
quand je avec nous avec les PSA et
Renault qui sont un peu les acteurs des
base au centre de la plateforme et il a
tous les grands équipementties et après
les petits équipementiures et et dans
ces cadre là aussi on anime jé
personnellement censé aussi des des des
tirur de cette affaire et onanime
lespaule des compétitivités donc
régulièrement on s réunit avec les pôles
de compétitivité et et on essaie tous
ensemble de coordonner un peu les S de
recherche et sur les différents domaines
techniques qui nous intéressent autour
des ces grands programmes que son
aujourd'hui les véhicules électriques
les véhicules connectés les véhicules
autonomes et puis la la la réduction un
peu des des consommations du du des
véhicules conventionnels et notamment de
de ce côté-là on a pris une initiative
qui très tôt euh il va il va être connu
c'est dans les prochains satellères de
la plateforme automobile on va tenter
une nouvelle approche justement pour
tirer un petit peu plus profit des des
pôles de compétitivité pour les mieux
les orienter vers la la la recherche et
vers la la la les innovations techniques
appliquées des EU montrer un espèce de
cahè de charg très précis et dont les
constructeurs automobiles ils ont
vraiment besoin euh des des nouvelles
idées d'une façon beaucoup plus concrète
que dans le passés c'est-à-dire au lieu
de de définir d'une façon très très très
peu précis au trè très au trop général
les sax de recherche dire exement qui
ont les éléments techniques dont on a
besoin pour améliorer la compétitivité
des des constructeurs et de cette
façon-là vraiment posouser des vrais
programmes qui se réalisent des
programmes vraiment qui on en côté
applicatif important ça c'est une chose
et en plus de ça on travaille évidemment
aussi avec beaucoup des des
d'institutions des recherch et et des
des des
d'établissements de recherche on
travaille avec par exemple l'institut
vdcom qui a été créé justement autour du
du véhicule autonome on on travaille sur
la sécurité des logiciels et des
systèmes embarqués dans les véhicules
avec les les les institut systémic et
donc on a je peux vous citer tout un
ensemble mais ça serait assez long
desintitut de recherche s lesquels et
vraiment on s'appuie pour pouvoir faire
ces recherches fondamentales que
finalement bon il s'applique sous les
véhicules les véhicules qu'on
conçoit monsieur Vial il vous a posé la
question parce que près de chez lui où
il est élu on a visité à Greno un de vos
principaux partenaires
sur qui fait beaucoup de recherche
vraiment appliqué quoi et c'est un énant
quand il nous a dit que sur une sur un
véhicule il fournissait à peu près 1000
pièces 1000 1000 éléments alors on a
compris que la recherche l'écosystème on
a commencé à comprendre ce que ça
voulait dire très concrètement et en
réalité c'est un peu ce que nous pensons
nous nous pensons que le cire il faut
qu'il alimente
l'écosystème parce que en réalité c'est
des PME PMI en général des entreprise
intermédiaire et et c'est là qu'on a
besoin de de leur donner un peu de de
peps euh je deux questions pour terminer
à moins que le rapporteur a une question
encore avant c'est c'est une question à
mon collègue du Finistère je voudrais
pas le priver de parole merci monsieur
le Président j'ai été édifié comme
beaucoup par le contenu du reportage et
je remercie le président puisque j'avais
pas eu l'occasion de le voir de de
l'avoir montré et j'ai été rassuré à la
fois par les réponses qui nous ont été
apportées et puis par l'approche que
fait l'entreprise Renault de de la
recherche euh par son implantation en
France parce que nous voulons
effectivement que la France industrielle
puisse se développer et avec Peugeot
vous êtes l'un des principaux acteurs
industriels dans notre pays il importe
que nous puissions vous encourager alors
j'ai bien entendu l'organisation
notamment en terme matriciel he par type
d'activité avec pour la politique
sociale l'entité Renault SAS qui euh
regroupe l'ensemble des personnels et
qui permet d'avoir une approche globale
je présume et et donc les
euh l'organisation ensuite par centre de
profit je voulais savoir si euh les
différentes filiales dont on a parleré
tout à l'heure sont bénéficiaaires si
elles sont bénéficiaires de façon
significative effectivement au quel cas
ça permet de d'apporter notamment des
ressources en terme d'impôt sur les
sociétés et et puis d'autre part j'ai
pas bien entendu la réponse sur le fait
de savoir si vous aviez été l'objet de
contrôle au T du CIR par le les services
fiscaux d'accord alors le l'organisation
fiscale en France est est consolidée
donc toutes nos notre on
a un système fiscal où toutes nos
sociétés françaises sont consolidées
dans un même périmètre fiscal donc les
filiales qui sont là en l'occurrence des
sociétés de moyens comme une usine qui
est un centre de cour plus qu'autre
chose est consolidé avec la maison MRE
et tout ceci donne un résultat fiscal
unique qui est y compris notre banque
qui est intégrée dans le périmètre
fiscal français donc tout est rabattu
enfin tout vient en France et comme je
le disais toutes nos refacturations
atterriss en France et et c'est en
France qu'on a notre notre lias fiscal
unique effectivement le le le personnel
ça nous permet d'avoir un ingénieur ne
travaillera peut-être pas tout le temps
sur un véhicule utilitaire le jour où il
faudra passer un véhicule électrique
s'il était pas facile de le déplacer
d'un projet à l'autre on aurait autant
de filiales quas
qu'on a de projet et là vous multipliez
les coups administratifs et puis ça ça
crée des des situations de statut à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise qui qui
deviennent finalement assez difficile à
difficile à à à gérer alors oui nous
avons été contrôlés alors d'abord le
tout le dispositif est totalement publ
he il est il est il est communiqué dans
nos dans nos plaquettes qui sont déposé
à la le document de référence à la MF
donc le dispositif est évidemment connu
des euh des services fiscaux français
nous avons nous sommes régulièrement
audités et contrôlés et nous ces
sociétés ont toutes été contrôlé et
n'ont jamais fait l'objet d'un
commentaire ou d'un redressement et
encore moins d'un
redressement
pardon le
le c'est effectivement dans oui c'é une
de vos questions
voilà
alors pour terminer deux questions
monsieur messieur puisque madame de a
décidé de pas
intervenir problème fiscau avait l'air
de la
terroriser non ça va alors Monsieur
Gascan Bellan on on parle toujours de
notre souséquipement en robot no robot
on est sur disé alors vous êtes vraiment
dans l'activité où le robot la
fabrication de vos voitures est quand
même un élément
majeur alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire si par rapport à l'industrie
allemande j'ai j'ai visité pas en
Allemagne mais à Bratislava l'usine
Volkswagen où il faisait 15 Braban
maintenant ils font 1900 véhicules le
jour c'est impressionnant avec la
robotisation alors est-ce que notre
robotisation elle
est à la hauteur des enjeux
d'aujourd'hui oùou est-ce que nous avons
encore besoin sur le secteur de robot de
des de dépenser encore un peu de crédit
d'impôt recherche ensuite à Monsieur le
Directeur Financier ça c'est la question
qui n'a rien à voir avec le cire mais
qui peut avoir un rapport avec
l'ambiance vous avez pratiquement un des
plus gros budgets d'annonces
publicitaire si ce n'est le premier de
France je crois ou deè bon alors est-ce
que pouvez nous dire avec antenne 2 ça
représente
combien soit en pourcentage so en somme
si vous l'avez pas pas vous nous
l'enverrez
par vous nous l'enverrez vous essaierez
de nous l'envoyer ça doit être assez
c'est c'est c'est une question
d'ambiance he j'ai bien dit mais ça
serait quand même curieux que vous nous
disiez les trois dernières années
comment les choses ont évolué ça serait
intéressant voilà et puis voilà réponse
la dernière pour le faire par écrit par
contre les robots sur mes questions fond
propres et dans les dans les entités qui
étaient mises en questionnement et puis
le reven du droit voilà et puis euh
ensuite ben monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des finances il est convaincu
donc il ne pose pas de question donc on
conclura la la séance ok par rapport à
votre question sur la rétisation je vaux
pas rentrer dans un débat ultra
technique et mais vous pouvez on est
même capable de comprendre non mais
clairement je peux vous dire qu'on a une
réflexion au sein du groupe vraiment sur
comment améliorer la compétitivité des
des usines en France et et ça c'est une
des soucis majeurs que nous avons et et
nous avons étudié
différents différents propositions
d'optimisation de l'utille industriel et
naturellement ça passe autant sous
l'aspect qualité comme s l'aspect
productivité pure c'estàd coût de de
fabrication et effectivement la la
robotization c'est un outil et qui qui
devient très intéressant aujourd'hui
mais c'est un outil qui devient encore
plus intéressant quand on est dans des
fabrications à une certaine volume et
avec une certaine aussi flexibilité et
aujourd'hui la la la le groupe Renault
il s'est engagé sur une démarche
vraiment des
standardisation très fort des
plateformes qui permettent déjà pouvoir
écrire différents modèles à partir d'un
seul une seelle basse du véhicule il
permettre peut-être une utilisation
beaucoup plus efficace pardon de la
robotisation et à l'étude aujourd'hui
nous avons différents projets et pour
probablement l'utiliser beaucoup plus
massivement dans dans certains usines
françaises mais je peux pas vous
préciser plus parce que justement ce
sont des projets qui sont en
construction et que ils aboutiront d'ici
à quelques peu mais plutôt sur les court
term que s les long
euh je pense qu'on a eu un je pense un
débat
sérieux la la présentation effectivement
répond déjà à beaucoup des questions qui
et ça nous permet quand même
de d'avoir une vision quoi d'un grand
groupe français par rapport à la
recherche développement et qui complète
assez bien d'ailleurs beaucoup d'autres
auditions que nous avons eu sur ce sujet
donc nous ferons en sorte que dans le
rapport une page soit consacrée
spécifiquement à cette séance pour
remettre un peu les chos en ordre
Monsieur le Directeur Monsieur messieurs
les directeurs mesdames les directrices
merci de vous être dérangé d'avoir
répondu à l'ensemble de nos questions
avec beaucoup de
précision voilà pour cette audition sur
le thème du détournement de crédit impôt
recherche la commission d'enquête sur ce
sujet au Sénat recevait vous l'avez vu
deux repr représentant du groupe
automobile Renault son directeur
financier et son directeur de la
recherche le groupe automobile qui a été
mis en cause dans un reportage du
journal télévisé de France 2 le journal
de 20h dans un reportage les
journalistes montrent un mécanisme
d'optimisation fiscal qui serait utilisé
par Renault pour détourner une partie de
l'enveloppe de crédit impôt recherche
vous pouvezevir et revoir cette audition
et toutes les autres sur notre site
publicsenat.fr très bonne suite des
programmes sur les chaînes parle
com